now because Jennifer you took a bit of
friends when you left at the end and
took all five of them but in some of the
set you thought oh wait yes I got uh I
took a the neon the neon coffee mug from
the coffeehouse cuz you said as a
picture of it so wait was that in
Central Park
yes that's from the coffee house right
when you would walk in the door to the
right
yes Central Perk that's the thing I did
ask me though I didn't cuz that would be
a hell of a thing to try to take off a
set but Rhys Legally Blonde - yes
you walked away with more than most oh
well I got all my wardrobe yeah how many
how many pairs of Jimmy Choos like 77
[Music]
[Applause]
do you still had did you wear all 77 of
them all of them I did in the show yeah
but but and I've well no I've never
touched them and then on the 15th
anniversary I took them all out of
storage and tried them all on some of
them didn't
and then yeah yeah it was really cool
and I showed him all to my daughter and
it was very good you mentioned your
first husband who designed Mary Poppins
did you end up getting loads of those
problems no the only thing I did take
home and I think he may have done it for
me was the the the pretty little pink
and white button-up shoes another pair
of shoes from Mary Poppins outing with
with Burt those there yeah they're door
stops now they've moved filled with
filled with sand and look very pretty
[Music]